5 4 3 2 1
vous êtes prêts
on est prêt à oublier le lointain une
bonne fois pour toute
[Musique]
chez le cerveau en brûler depuis
quelques années
tout ce que j'ai toujours voulu c'est
être à mon père
tu as essayé de te faire aider non je
sais de me débrouiller seul
[Musique]
pourquoi tu amènerais pas Dalton à la
fac tes cours ne doivent pas commencer
avant quelques semaines non c'est qu'une
idée pour vous rapprocher je sais que
c'est compliqué entre vous
[Musique]
l'équilibre entre ombre et lumière voilà
ce que l'on recherche donc Théo
Beaux-Arts
je suis tombé dans le coma
mais j'ai aucun souvenir d'avoir été
malade
et voyez quelle lumière vous pourrez en
retirer
je vois des trucs flippants
je crois que c'est des seins pour être
des indices sur mon passé il y a
tellement de choses que tu ne sais pas
et j'avais trop peur de te dire la
vérité
famille a des secrets
[Musique]
ils ont effacé tous nos souvenirs mais
je sens toujours quelque chose qui nous
poursuit il y a qu'une seule façon de
savoir
j'ai l'impression de me rapprocher de
quelque chose
ou que quelque chose se rapproche de moi
quand vous réveillez les morts plus vous
vous aventurez loin plus votre voyage
devient dangereux